Here at DNews, we love space.
And we love cats.
So it’s about time we talk about cats in
space!
Well, sorta.
Hey all you earthbound suckers, Trace here
for DNews.
Today, we’re doing something a little different:
while poking around on the internet, we found
this science video that we could not figure
out.
In these experiments you can see the disorientation
resulting when an animal is suddenly placed
in a weightless state.
After watching that, we had to find out: where
did this footage come from?
And what is going on with those weightless
cats?
Well, it turns out the answer stretches back
to before NASA existed.
And those cats are still affecting our space
program today.
The space race began in 1957 with the Soviet
launch of Sputnik 1, the very first man-made
satellite.
That’s the actual sound of Sputnik 1 while
orbiting the Earth, by the way.
Sputnik lit a fire under the US to get to
space, and within 9 months, NASA was up and
running.
But it turns out, NASA wasn’t the only game
in town when it came to space research.
The American military had been studying the
effects of extreme flight on pilots since
World War I.
And they knew that if we were going to beat
the Russians to space, we’d need to understand
how the human body responds to changes in
gravity…like the huge g-forces of a rocket
launch or the zero-gravity environment of
orbit.
And how did we study new and dangerous things
in the 50s?
With animals.
Here’s a rocket test from 1952, five years
before NASA was founded.
Onboard were two Philippine monkeys and two
white mice.
They became some of the very first animals
to survive a rocket flight, and that gave
us some of our earliest data on both extreme
g-forces and zero gravity.
Brave, brave rocket monkeys.
But anyway.
In 1958, NASA comes online with the immediate
goal of getting an American into orbit.
But they don’t have the facilities or scale
to conduct all their experiments.
So in 1961, in steps an Air Force department
called the Aerospace Medical Division, or
AMD.
They work with NASA on experiments designed
to get the Project Mercury spaceflight program
up to snuff.
And they are some pretty intense tests.
Here’s the AMD trying out an ejection seat
for a fighter jet:
“The main parachute starts to deploy, but
in this particular test, it collapsed partially.
The subject received an opening shock, estimated
at 16.5 G, and lost consciousness.”
The AMD ran most of their tests on humans,
but, you guessed it...they’re also responsible
for this video.
In order to study weightless animals without
actually sending them into orbit, AMD loaded
cats, and also pigeons, into a cargo plane
and sent it into a controlled free fall…
voila, zero Gs.
And 60 years later... double voila, internet
gold!
But what on Earth can kicking cats around
a cargo plane teach us about humans in space?
Well, a lot.
In 1961, the AMD published a paper that described
techniques to help people rotate themselves
while floating in zero gravity.
Experiments like these taught us: the “Bend
and Twist,” the “Lasso,” and, wait for
it…the “Cat Reflex.”
Which looks a lot like this.
The point is: basic things like how to move
your own body are not intuitive in space.
But by copying nature, scientists taught our
astronauts how to survive in orbit, and beyond.
So thanks to a lot of hard work by NASA and
the Air Force, we now have footage of floating
scientists juggling cats.
Your tax dollars at work.
...The pigeons, though… we still have no
idea what that’s all about.
Nowadays, scientists put smaller animals into
orbit to test all sorts of things.
Check out our video on one experiment that
we probably should have used birds and bees
for...